[Aplausos]
[Música]
australia es uno de los países más ricos
del mundo es más hasta antes de la
pandemia podían presumir de no haber
sufrido ninguna crisis económica sin
embargo se habrían nombrarme alguna
empresa australiana pensando bien
hablamos del país del futuro
[Música]
basta con echar un vistazo a ciudades
como melbourne o sydney para imaginarse
cómo será el mundo en 2050 y da igual el
ranking que miremos australia siempre
está en los mejores puestos los
australianos disfrutan del segundo
salario mínimo más alto del planeta con
casi dos mil euros al mes además son una
de las economías más libres del mundo
donde es más fácil hacer negocios pero a
la vez con un estado del bienestar
envidiable cuando el mundo entero sufría
la gran crisis financiera los
australianos estaban creciendo a ritmos
del 2% del pib e incluso ahora con la
crisis del coronavirus australia puede
presumir de estar en una situación mucho
mejor que casi cualquier otro país
[Música]
en otras palabras que australia es un
país rico muy rico
sin embargo vuelvo a la misma pregunta
haces alguna empresa australiana
posiblemente no muchas tal vez os suene
la aerolínea qantas también es
australiana la marca de ropa ripcurl y
si hay algún compañero youtuber por aquí
y tal vez conozcáis otra más road
micrófonos por ejemplo este micrófono
del que estoy hablando es de esta marca
y si estos micrófonos son australianos
en cualquier caso hablamos de empresas
relativamente pequeñas la pregunta es
dónde está el google o el bmw
australiano
[Música]
por eso la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es de dónde viene esa riqueza tan
impresionante de australia que venden al
mundo para ser tan ricos hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
ya que vamos a hablar del país del sur
por antonomasia vamos a hablar de
surfear en internet internet cada vez
tienen más restricciones geográficas así
que si queréis poder navegar por
internet libremente incluso por páginas
web australianas tendréis que usar una
vpn
[Música]
y cuál es la vpn favorita de visual
política pues ya lo sabéis todos sus
shark vpn surfers que es nube pn
fantástica y súper segura por ejemplo no
os ha pasado alguna vez que entráis en
una página web o salen un montón de
ventanitas de publicidad pues a eso se
le llama fishing y por ahí se cuelan
montones de cookies y de virus que se
meten en el ordenador y también en el
teléfono móvil hay cuidado con lo que
hacemos con el teléfono móvil que eso es
como un imán para los vídeos
pues bien cursar como ya sabéis todos
tienen una herramienta que se llama
clean web que bloquea todos estos popup
si todos estos enlaces que pueden ser un
auténtico peligro pero no sólo eso con
una única cuenta de surf shark poder
registrar todos los dispositivos que
queráis el móvil la tablet el portátil
no hay ningún límite de dispositivos
y como siempre tenemos una oferta muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguís
visual política básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado en catch
tendréis un 83% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratis es más
podéis probar seur shark durante los
primeros 30 días sin ningún compromiso
en la descripción nos dejó en los
enlaces y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
tierra de oportunidades en el año 1788
australia no era más que una colonia
penal británica es decir era el lugar
donde reinó unido- mandaba a sus presos
tal cual como louis para que la
australiana moderna que conocemos se
convirtiera en uno de los países más
ricos del mundo fue fundamental el
olfato para los negocios de una serie de
buscavidas el primero de nuestros
protagonistas es john mcarthur un
militar británico que hizo llegar a
australia ovejas merinas españolas con
las que fundó un imperio de la lana así
es como empezó todo en australia y de
hecho esto quedó inmortalizado en la
siguiente frase
australia cabalgó hacia la prosperidad a
lomos de las ovejas desde entonces
australia sigue siendo el principal
productor de lana del mundo y el señor
macarthur ha quedado inmortalizado en
los billetes de este país echad los
invitados
lo que está claro es que en australia
había sitio más que suficiente para
tener grandes rebaños de ovejas pero es
que además la historia ha sido la gran
aliada de la lana australiana gran
bretaña compró toda la producción
australiana durante la segunda guerra
mundial y durante la guerra de korea sus
precios se dispararon por la demanda
estadounidense de lana para vestir a sus
tropas lo que pasa es que los tiempos
cambian y hoy en día los compradores
también cambian
[Música]
el precio de la lana en australia sube a
medida que repunta a la demanda de china
pero esperad un momento mis queridos
amigos de visual polític porque no solo
de lana vive el hombre a mediados del
siglo 19 estalló en australia toda una
fiebre del oro que nada tiene que
envidiar a las vividas en otros países
desde entonces australia sigue siendo el
principal productor de oro del mundo
pero espera un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de oro en realidad australia
tiene de todo hierro carbón aluminio
cobre uranio y por supuesto gas natural
y petróleo ambos que sería más fácil
empezar diciendo lo que no tienen
[Música]
si a esto le sumamos que están al lado
de asia ya tenemos toda la historia
quien pone todos los recursos naturales
para todo ese crecimiento fantástico de
china y del sudeste asiático exacto
australia y gracias a esto australia
está en rica pregunta resuelta y hemos
terminado fin del vídeo estado
qué nombre y cómo me iba a ir todo iba a
daros una respuesta tan simple en visual
político ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
si de verdad sois seguidores de visual
polític de esos que no se pierde ninguno
de nuestros vídeos porque le ha dado la
campanita suscribirse ya sabéis que
tener recursos naturales no significa
absolutamente nada si tener recursos
naturales fuera sinónimo de ser rico
argentina sería suiza y suiza sería
argentina es más en realidad de lo que
sí que podríamos hablar es de la
maldición de los recursos naturales así
que la pregunta es como evitado
australia esa maldición de los recursos
naturales pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
viejas riquezas nuevas técnicas ya lo
sabéis tener recursos naturales no
siempre es una buena noticia de lo
contrario áfrica sería el continente más
rico del mundo cuando un país descubre
recursos naturales suelen ocurrir una de
estas dos cosas a esta nada del congo
tienen enormes reservas de tantalio y se
forman guerrillas que se matan entre
ellas para explotarlo de escenario de
venezuela tienen petróleo así que basan
toda su economía en exportarlo y se
arruinan cuando el precio de mercado del
barril cae sin embargo austral eligió
otro camino totalmente distinto
[Música]
los australianos siempre han tenido
muchísimos recursos naturales pero el
auténtico punto de la minería
australiana llegó hace 40 años
en ese momento australia ya tenía
instituciones democráticas transparentes
y libres a fin de cuentas habían copiado
el modelo de reino unido- y diréis pri
por qué es tan importante que todo esto
fuera así pues porque en australia se
formó el caldo de cultivo perfecto para
que allí hoy en día vivan en el futuro
bhp planea un gran despliegue de
automatización en australia robots de
minería riotinto duplica la perforación
autónoma en otras palabras que el sector
minero de australia no se parece en nada
a la imagen que podéis tener a la cabeza
de un minero con su pico y con su pala
al contrario al tener unas instituciones
que permitan la creación de empresas y
la competencia las mineras australianas
han tenido que apostar por la innovación
hoy en día la minería es uno de los
sectores más tecnológicos que existen
empresas como hp o riotinto son como el
apple de los recursos naturales así que
australia ya no solo exporta recursos
también exporta tecnología y eso explica
que muchas empresas australianas
exploten los recursos de otros países
lundin vende la mina de oro más grande
de ecuador a una minera australiana
gracias a todo esto que os estamos
contando es evidente que australia le ha
ido muy bien las cosas como son
precisamente hace más de 50 años nos
avanzó cómo sería el país el que por
aquel entonces era su primer ministro
atentos
[Música]
esta australia nuestra es un vasto
continente insular habitado en gran
parte por personas de origen británico o
europeo y con un legado de libertad
nacional libertad personal y las
instituciones de una democracia
parlamentaria británica pero
geográficamente somos parte de asia y
cada vez hemos tomado más conciencia de
nuestra participación en los asuntos de
asia heart on hold primer ministro
australiano de 1966 a 1967 y si estar
cerca de asia ha sido crucial para la
economía de australia el hierro ha
superado a la grana como principal
producto de exportación de australia
gracias a la demanda de las acerías
chinas así que igual que los países
árabes se hicieron de oro con el boom
del precio del petróleo
australia se ha beneficiado del
crecimiento económico de asia en las
últimas décadas
[Música]
australia apenas consume un 15% de su
producción de carbón y no producen poco
carbón precisamente un 8 por ciento de
lo que se produce en todo el planeta lo
que le convierte en el cuarto mayor
productor después de china indonesia y
eeuu así que el resto lo vende lo que
hace que australia sea el mayor
exportador mundial con una cuota de
mercado del 27 por ciento sólo japón y
china- compran ya más de la mitad del
carbón que exporta australia
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque si todos
estos datos del carbón son muy buenos
para australia y no tanto para el
planeta tenéis que ver lo que ha pasado
con el boom del gas natural licuado ya
os hemos contado unas cuantas veces aquí
en visual política la historia de nl o
gas natural licuado el gas natural se
puede transportar de dos formas en
gasoducto es decir con kilómetros y
kilómetros de tubos para llevar al gas
natural o como gn el gas natural licuado
es decir enfriar el gas hasta pasarlo a
estado líquido lo metes en buques
metaneros y lo envías a la planta
regasificadora de destino pues bien el
despertar económico de china y el apagón
nuclear de japón han disparado la
demanda de gas en asia y quien estaba
cerca para aprovecharse de todo esto
efectivamente australia y sus reservas
de gas en realidad no es que tengan
muchísimo gas realmente hablamos del 1
por ciento de las estimaciones actuales
de todo el planeta
para que os hagáis una idea qatar tiene
10 veces más gas sin embargo australia
es el segundo exportador de gas natural
del mundo aún así son suficientes para
que la producción de asís está de
australia se haya triplicado en los
últimos 10 años pasando de ser el décimo
octavo país quien más gas produce del
mundo a ser el séptimo productor mundial
así que australia está a un paso de
entrar en la champions league de los
productores de gas y como apenas
consumen un tercio del gas que producen
que creéis que hacen con los otros dos
tercios
[Música]
pues efectivamente lo enfría lo meten en
su barco metanero y lo manda para asia
como estáis viendo australia tiene
muchos motivos para el optimismo y ya sé
lo que estará pensando algunos vamos
aver fonseca lo que estás describiendo
es una economía muy dependiente de los
recursos naturales en visual politics
siempre nos contáis que eso es un
problema gordísimo de verdad australia
es la excepción pues no no lo es ahora
vamos a ver la cara más oscura de la
economía australiana
[Música]
y el mal holandés si descubrir recursos
naturales suele provocar que se
multipliquen los gobernantes corruptos
con australia podemos aprender que aún
teniendo buenos gobernantes tarde o
temprano aparecen los problemas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
fundamentalmente porque si para hacer
fortuna te vale con [ __ ] una pala y
excavar porque en australia siempre
encuentras algo pues es evidente que no
hay incentivos para desarrollar otras
industrias diferentes a la minería pero
esperad un momento mis queridos amigos
de visual político porque hay algo aún
peor hay problemas que son como una
infección que se extiende por toda la
economía hablamos del llamado mal
holandés y diréis qué es esto del mal
holandés pues básicamente es que te pase
lo mismo que le pasó a los países bajos
cuando descubrieron campos de gas en los
años 70 os pongo un ejemplo de repente
un país descubre cantidades ingentes de
un recurso pongamos que es pues yo que
sé el hierro australiano de repente
tienes tanto hierro que le da salida
exportándolo vendiéndoselo a empresas de
otros países pero atentos cuál es la
moneda del comercio internacional
[Música]
el dólar estadounidense en otras
palabras que las mineras australianas
ingresan millones y millones de dólares
estadounidenses pero luego tienen que
pagar sus impuestos en australia con que
pues con dólares australianos y entonces
que hacen pues comprar moneda local es
decir cambiar sus dólares
estadounidenses por dólares australianos
y qué significa todo esto pues que de
repente la demanda del dólar australiano
se dispara y qué pasa cuando se dispara
la demanda de una divisa pues que crece
su precio es decir que en lugar de
devaluarse la moneda se revalúa fijaos
en este gráfico
[Música]
como veis desde el año 2000 hasta el año
2011 el dólar australiano ha duplicado
su valor respecto al estadounidense tras
el año 2011 esta valoración se ha
moderado y durante la crisis del
coronavirus el dólar australiano ha
caído un poquito todo esto qué significa
pues que por fin los australianos están
empezando a experimentar un poco de
inflación
[Aplausos]
y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando
desde cuándo es malo que tu divisa no se
devalúe teóricamente el mejor escenario
para un país sería el de tener una
divisa fuerte verdad así los ciudadanos
no sufren inflación y pueden hacer
inversiones en el largo plazo en otras
palabras que al tener una moneda tan
cara los australianos tienen más poder
adquisitivo y casi cualquier ciudadano
de otro país es decir que un australiano
puede viajar por el mundo y todo le
parecerá barato puede permitirse comprar
cualquier cosa del extranjero con más
facilidad que un estadounidense o un
europeo verdad pues si tenéis razón pero
también tener una moneda que se revalúa
constantemente tiene sus problemas y
diréis qué problemas pues atentos
[Música]
cierre de holden la historia australiana
de fabricación de automóviles llega a su
fin primero cerro ford luego toyota y
finalmente lo hizo golden y cars toy o
tie ford seguro que sabéis que son
firmas de japón y de eeuu pero holden
aunque formaba parte del grupo general
motors es la marca por excelencia del
coche australiano
[Música]
bueno más bien deberíamos decir que lo
era porque en febrero del 2020 cerraron
definitivamente y diréis y qué es lo
relevante del cierre de las fábricas de
coches en australia pues que en el fondo
es todo un símbolo de las penurias por
las que está pasando la industria
manufacturera australiana
[Música]
el mal holandés ha hecho que australia
pierda competitividad por todos los
lados porque al tener sueldos tan altos
es muy difícil competir con el
extranjero y ya sé lo que estará
pensando alguno venga ya fonseca o sea
si eso fuera cierto quizá no tendría
empresas pues si tenéis razón el
problema es que suiza no tiene recursos
mineros y ahí es donde entra el mal
holandés los sueldos altos hacen que
solo sea rentable crear industrias de
altísimo valor añadido pero la gente que
podría creer esas industrias está
demasiado ocupada trabajando en el ultra
rentable mundo de la minería conclusión
en pocos años toda tu autonomía depende
de tus recursos naturales en otras
palabras que te acabas de convertir en
arabia saudita
e
para que os hagáis una idea más de la
mitad de las exportaciones de australia
son recursos naturales de hecho hay todo
un ranking en la que australia sí que
está a la altura de otros países tan
poco ejemplares como burkina faso o
uganda a qué ranking me estoy refiriendo
al ranking de complejidad económica esta
ranking mide por un lado el nivel de
diversificación de un país y la
diferenciación de sus productos
por ejemplo en este índice japón es el
país más complejo y diréis por qué pues
porque japón exporta un montón de
productos tecnológicos de alto valor
añadido una televisión sonny es una
televisión sonny distinta de cualquier
otra marca de televisiones sin embargo
una tonelada de hierro es igual en todas
partes pues bien en este terreno
australia sale muy mal parada y diréis
entonces todo esto significa que los
australianos están al borde de ser una
nueva venezuela o una nueva arabia
saudita para nada de entrada australia
cuenta con unas instituciones sólidas
como para que una vez la minería dejará
de ser rentable pudieran surgir otras
industrias rápidamente de hecho esto es
exactamente lo que ocurrió en países
bajos
países bajos es el país que puso nombre
al mal holandés sin embargo creo que
nadie puede decirme que hoy en día sean
una economía poco diversa o que estén en
declive pero no sólo eso a diferencia de
otros países australia cuenta con unos
políticos que saben mirar a largo plazo
y eso explica campañas como ésta
de nuevo
es nuestro taxi de disney para esta
campaña la encontramos en bloomberg que
como sabéis es uno de los medios de
comunicación más grandes del campo de
las finanzas y la promueve el estado de
victoria con capital en melbourne en
general los políticos australianos están
moviendo para diversificar la economía y
para ello están intentando atraer
inversiones extranjeras que contribuyan
a desarrollar más sectores innovadores
[Música]
el gobierno de victoria trae empresas
tecnológicas para invertir en el estado
los resultados de este tipo de campañas
se recogerán en el medio plazo y aún es
difícil evaluarlas pero si sabemos que
ya hay toda una nueva generación de
jóvenes compañías australianas que han
empezado a abrirse camino en el mundo de
la economía digital desde el país de los
canguros hablamos de plataformas para
trabajadores freelance como freelancer o
ninety-nine designs que son australianas
también fintech como youtube bank o
software avanzado como campa así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que todos estos esfuerzos para
superar el mal holandés serán
suficientes consideráis que australia
podría ser el lugar ideal si tuvierais
que emprender un nuevo negocio podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual politics sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]